peut-être savez-vous que platon a
qualifié le corps de tombeau en grec
c'est un jeu de mot entre soma le corps
et sema le tombeau alors on comprend
bien que l'expression et péjoratives ce
qui est cohérent parce qu'un philosophe
n'est pas un bodybuilder qui voue un
véritable culte au corps mais dans le
détail par les deux tombeaux et
énigmatique on résoudre cette énigme
il faut voir comment platon conçoit les
rapports de l'âme et du corps vous allez
voir que la question est loin d'être
subsidiaire parce qu'elle est en fait
lié à la raison d'être de la philosophie
je suis romain et vous êtes sur mille
idées de culture générale
[Musique]
alors avant de rentrer dans le détail de
libé je vous donne quelques éléments
pour préparer le terrain première chose
à savoir platon n'a pas théorisé les
rapports de l'âme et du corps dans un
dialogue particulier c'est en fait une
question qui traversent son oeuvre
on la retrouve notamment dans le gore
gias le phédon le banquet le team et et
à des degrés moindres et sous d'autres
angles dans d'autres dialogues encore
donc c'était bien une question
importante pour plateau deuxième chose
comme vous le savez peut-être déjà dans
les dialogues de platon
c'est généralement que son maître
socrates qui parle et on peut donc
soupçonner le disciple de se servir de
lui pour diffuser ses propres thèses du
coup on confond un peu leur pensée par
commodité
ce qui veut dire qu'en pratique les
idées que j'attribue à platon dans ces
vidéos peuvent avoir été exprimée par la
bouche de socrate
enfin troisième informations
préliminaires la théorie platonicienne
et dualiste c'est à dire qu'il distingue
d'un côté un monde matériel dont tous
les éléments sont caractérisés par des
propriétés physiques et de l'autre côté
un monde spirituel ou immatériel dont
les éléments comme la pensée échappe au
chant de la physique et c'est bien pour
ça que le titre de la vidéo c'est l'âme
et le corps selon platon l'âme
appartient au monde spirituel le corps
au monde matériel dont platon lui est un
tenant du dualisme position qui
s'opposent aux monisme du grec mono ce
qui veut dire seul unique le monisme
c'est quand on considère que tout est
réductible à un seul et unique principe
bref je ne rentre pas dans le détail des
variétés de monisme de dualisme google
est votre ami
retenez seulement que la réflexion
l'atonie sienne et dualiste allez on est
prêt pour passer aux choses sérieuses
pourquoi qualifier le corps de tombeaux
pas très sympa quand même
[Musique]
on ne pas faire comme les journalistes
qui tronquent les déclarations des
personnalités publiques
je vais tout d'abord citer la citation
précise de platon tiré du gorgias tu
sais en réalité nous sommes morts
je l' ai déjà entendu dire par des
hommes qui se connaissent ils
soutiennent qu'à présent nous sommes
morts que notre corps est un tombe ce
que dit cette citation c'est que la vie
dans le corps n'est pas la vraie vie
celle qui a du sens de la valeur et qui
mérite d'être vécue vivre dans et par le
corps c'est être mort parce que le corps
polluent et freine la vie de l'esprit
oui platon il est philosophe a body
builder donc forcément il survalorise un
peu la vie intellectuelle
sa théorie à lui c'est plus précisément
que la finalité de la vie c'est d'élever
l'âme jusqu'à la vérité vous le savez
peut-être pour platon la vérité est
situé dans un monde à part un monde
spirituel distinct du monde matériel le
monde des idées qui sont les essences de
la réalité or on n'accède pas à ce monde
des idées en prenant un ascenseur non il
faut sérieusement s'exercer à la
philosophie faut être concentré pour
penser clairement et en profondeur le
corps est un obstacle évident à cet
effort les exigences du corps comme
l'alimentation la sécurité le confort
matériel
le désir sexuel etc empêche l'individu
de philosopher librement la santé et
bien sûr une autre condition nécessaire
pour atteindre la vérité parce que la
maladie nuit à la réflexion
la vie sentimentale également qui est
déterminé par le cor perturbent la vie
de l'esprit larnaca par même une grande
part difficile d'accéder au monde des
idées quand il y à t'il d'heure bref le
corps et pour platon un obstacle à
l'épanouissement de l'âme ce qui est le
véritable sens de l'existence
c'est pour ça que vivre dans son corps
c'est un peu comme vivre dans un ton ce
tombeau n'est toutefois pas éternel
parce que comme le dit socrates dans un
moment d'optimisme la mort nous en
délivrera off
mais ce qu'il faut pour autant méprisée
et
négliger le corps a considéré l'ensemble
de l'oeuvre de platon les choses ne sont
pas si simples que le suggère le mot de
tombes en fait le corps n'est pas un mal
on lui même il n'est pas un obstacle à
supprimer par l'a16 philosophique ou en
accueillant la mort à bras ouverts le
corps peut devenir un problème
dans son rapport à l'âme s'il sort de la
suggestion à son égard qui est sa place
naturelle en clair il existe entre l'âme
et le corps une hiérarchie qui doit être
à tout prix préserver ce n'est donc pas
le corps en lui même qui empêche le
philosophe d'accéder à la vérité au
monde des idées c'est en fait une forme
de désordre dans le corps qui constitue
une entrave à l'épanouissement
philosophique
or pour platon c'est à l'âme de
préserver l'ordre souhaitable dans le
corps
c'est en cela que l'âme est responsable
du corps si elle ne tient pas son rôle
c'est à dire si l'individu laisse son
corps à la démesure
s'il se dissipe dans les plaisirs
corporels alors effectivement son corps
sera un tomb platon donne même des
instructions plus précises
si l'âme veut que le corps la laisse
philosopher tranquillement il faut
qu'elle veille à ce que l'ordre du corps
correspondre à l'ordre de l'univers
cette adéquation nécessaire entre
l'ordre du corps est celui de l'univers
elle signifie que le désordre dans le
corps menace par extension la réalité
toute entière l'at on écrit à ce propos
de toute façon si l'âme n'était pas là
pour surveiller le corps si le corps
était laissé à lui même alors toutes les
réalités serait confondu pêle-mêle et
reviendrait au même
l'enjeu n'est donc pas mince il en va de
la réalité tout entière du coup le
philosophe ne doit pas négliger le corps
au contraire il doit s'astreindre
incertaine ascétisme corporelle c'est à
dire le soumettre à une certaine rigueur
afin d'éviter la démesure
d'y préserver l'ordre c'est à cette
condition que le corps peut ne pas
perturber l'âme dans sa quête de la
vérité
à ce stade la dépréciation du corps est
déjà plus nuancée par rapport à ce que
suggère l'idée d'un ton mais vous allez
voir que platon est allé encore plus
loin en allant dans le détail la
conception de l'âme et du corps de
platon n'est pas aussi univoque qu'un
examen rapide pourrait le laisser croire
alors platon et bien dualiste il affirme
bien la primauté de l'âme sur le corps
mais leurs rapports sont plus complexes
qu'il n'y paraît il ya des exceptions
qui donne au corps un rôle insoupçonnées
une vertu philosophique en effet le
corps serait capable d'aider l'âme à
atteindre la vérité à pénétrer le monde
des idées
l'idée plus globale c'est que
l'expérience sensible peut servir de
tremplin pour la pensée ce sont parfois
des circonstances du matériel qui
déclenche la réflexion philosophique
il ya même des allers et retours entre
la pensée théorique et le monde matériel
qui est le monde du corps at on admet
plus généralement que l'homme ne pense
pas à partir de rien mais toujours
forcément
depuis sa situation incarné il croyait
bien dans la réminiscence c'est à dire
en l'idée que l'âme aurait vécu dans le
monde des idées avant d'intégrer un
corps mais se rappeler cette vie
antérieure n'est pas facile ni immédiat
c'est un processus qui est déclenchée
par des signes dans le monde matériel au
clair ce monde matériel donne
paradoxalement à l'âme l'occasion de
s'élever hors de lui vers le monde des
idées ce qui veut dire que le corps lui
même est aussi le moyen de la vérité
l'at on donne l'exemple de la beauté
pour lui le sentiment si particulier
quant à quand on contemple une belle
personne eh bien il est dû au fait que
notre âme se rappelle sa vie antérieure
dans le monde des idées où elle a
notamment côtoyé l'idée du bon si la
contemplation du beau corps est une
expérience forte c'est parce que l'idée
bo était particulièrement attirante dans
la vie antérieure de la et donc son
souvenir est très ancré en nous
[Musique]
soc
mon avis c'est plus une histoire
d'hormones que de réincarnation mais bon
cette expérience de la contemplation du
beau corps c'est donc selon platon un
chemin vers l'idée du bon c'est plus
précisément la première étape de la
contemplation du bon en soi la beauté
illustre ainsi la vertu philosophique du
corps il est capable avec un peu
d'entraînement d'initier à la
contemplation des idées alors pas mal
pour un tango n'ont que retenir de la
conception platonicienne des rapports de
l'âme et du corps je pense qu'on peut
synthétiser tout le propos de platon
avec ses nuances insoupçonnées en disant
que le corps est très généralement
surtout un risque mais qui peut aussi
être un atout avec la pratique
philosophique pour accéder au ciel des
idées
si on ne fait pas attention si on
maintient pas un certain ordre du corps
alors là oui il peut devenir un tombeau
au sens où ils nous privent par ses
servitudes de la vie véritable qui est
ailleurs la vie philosophe mais si l'âme
assume sa responsabilité à l'égard du
corps alors elle peut en faire un
tremplin vers le monde des idées de la
même manière dont l'expérience de la
beauté corporelle nous ramène à l'idée
du bon ce que dit platon c'est donc que
le corps est un tombeau pour l'homme
ordinaire celui qui ne sort jamais de la
caverne qui se laissent abuser par
l'illusion est dominé par ses patients
le philosophe en quête de vérité lui est
capable de remettre le corps à sa place
dans sa relation avec l'âme
ce qui est frappant dans cette
conception c'est que le corps ait pensé
par rapport à la vérité par rapport à
son statut épistémologique dirait ton
plus techniquement même si on l'a vu la
tombe ne dévalorise pas tout ce qui est
corporelle ces idées sont tout de même
assez révélatrice je trouve de la
propension des philosophes à
survaloriser forcément le champ
intellectuel par
or auchan matériel si vous avez aimé la
vidéo donne et lui impose bleus et
abonnez-vous à la chaîne peut être
prévenue de la sortie la suivante si
vous voulez lire ma synthèse de l'idée
de platon sur le site mis des cultures
finale le lien est dans la description
n'hésitez pas non plus à laisser vos
commentaires enfin si vous voulez
recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisée dans le format le
plus clair possible
vous pouvez vous abonner à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse email sur le
site
je suis romain et vous étiez sur mille
de culture générale rappelez vous que
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur
de la pensée
[Musique]